uh we're always delighted to have
candace owens the host of candace on our
airwaves
and she joins us now what do you make of
uh these
uh this move to uh sacrifice your
children's
education candace it's just becoming
increasingly more bizarre first and
foremost the self-flagellation that goes
on in these communities and
pretty much sums up beta or work who
seems to be a political masochist
but then when you talk about what
they're actually calling for it's
interesting because you could identify
this
as the bigotry of low expectations
they're saying that black americans
aren't smart enough to get into these
schools
um by their own merit right so there's
that going on but here's what's more
interesting it's worse than the bigger
tree of low expectations just a bigotry
of no expectations
in reality because we already have
affirmative action we haven't done away
with the form of action so they're
already more likely
to give a spot in a school to a black
american who has grades that are lower
than a white american that already
exists and they're saying that's not
even enough right
we need to just remove white people from
the school and of course obviously point
to the obvious which is that they never
think through any of their policies long
term
because it makes no sense what you're
saying is make sure these white people
cannot go into any ivy league schools
okay well then they're not going to be
ivy league schools anymore right if
you're saying now you just want to make
sure everybody there
has brown skin and you know fully well
that asian americans uh you know are
ranking at the top of their classes and
it's not it's not white americans then
what you're really saying is that you're
just gonna
reverse and change it around make the
schools that are lower are going to have
the smarter kids and then you're going
to have the kid places like
harvard and columbia are not going to
have the brightest kids so this doesn't
even make sense
long term you know so it's just it's
just such foolishness and you're right
to point out to the fact
that as we're focused on this woke
learning
the countries that are looking to take
us over in the east are
advancing they're not focused on this
type of academic learning or
non-academic learning is what i should
say
absolutely that's the right way how long
i mean i don't
i'm not sure there's a delicate way to
put this candace
but there's a a contradiction isn't
there because we're told incessantly
america is the most racist place on
earth historically racist racist for
centuries it will require at least half
a millennium to get the racism out of
the system
and yet whenever you see any news
stories from the
southern border there are ghanaians
there are
gambians there are key there are there
were people from majority black
countries
all trying to flee all trying to break
into the most racist
nation on earth what's the deal with
that right it seems increasingly bizarre
and listen i'll give them credit
america uh with with liberals and
progresses at the helm of it is
certainly becoming an increasingly more
systematically racist country that's
what they want that's what they're
asking for
that's exactly what this open letter is
demanding we want more systemic racism
we want people to focus on skin color
and make sure people are segregated
according to their skin color they want
every action in this country
to be informed by the color people's
skin i mean just look at that what you
just showed that montage of beta talking
about is white privilege
do you want to hear when a white person
looks at me and says i have privilege
because i'm white
that's racist you're saying to me
candace you're a black girl so you don't
understand
i'm better than you and hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else